there's a lady she's just sworn in as
Schoolboard president in Pennsylvania
and she wanted to take the oath of
office usually you swear the oath of
office on a Bible if you're not
Christian and you're a public office
holder let say you're Muslim I guess you
could swear it on the
Quran I if let's say you're Jewish I
guess you could swear it on the Torah
said but you swear it on on a book
traditionally that that means a lot to
you that you that and that speaks to
obligations that you have beyond the
material world that you because what
you're vowing is I will uphold my office
with Integrity I will not deceive I will
not cheat I will not lie so help me God
because even even if I won't be held to
account in this life I will be held to
account in the life to come that's why
you do it it's it's a book that you hold
sacred and the books that this lady
holds sacred are
pornography this this woman Karen
Smith decided to swear the oath of
office on a stack of banned books this
of course thanks to our friends at Libs
of Tik Tok who that you know she just
digs up all the greatest stuff the books
are not even the usual band books that
that people site you know uh I don't
know the the Harper Lee novel what's
that called you know I can't believe I
it's one of most famous novels ever
written they sometimes say that that
that's a band book or I don't know
catcher in the Ry or something no it's
but those aren't the books that are
really banned the books that are banned
are usually weirdo porn that they're
putting into elementary
schools well what are these books
flamer by Henry Holt all boys aren't
Blue by something
Johnson there's a Tony Morrison novel in
there which the reason people shouldn't
read Tony Morrison she's not a very good
writer not because it's pornographic
exactly Lillian Duncan Donna Gart so
even here flamer what we're talking
about is porn like in this case like
weird gay porn I I'm glad to see gender
queer wasn't in there I'm sure that
someone's going to include that too look
this makes sense to me it makes sense
that the the libs would consider the
most sacred books in the world to be
books that are poorly written and porn
pornographic in some
cases that's what they hold
sacred bad writing weak art and
obscenity that's what they hold sacred
they don't see it like that what they
see it like is that they are swearing
the oath on freedom and openness they
have a mistaken conception of freedom
and unopen we want to read every there
should be no banned books and the irony
here of course is the the book that one
would traditionally swear the oath of
office on is the one book that is
actually banned in schools and that's
the Bible and and this scbo lady seems
fine with that because she she kicked
the Bible out of her oath of office
that's the irony there's only one book
that is actually banned in schools
throughout the country and that book is
the Bible the rest of the stuff your
mileage may vary by municipality but
largely the weirdo porn stuff and the
bad writing and the nonsense is
permitted they want Total
openness now this is attractive even to
a lot of right-wingers they say that's
right we want freedom and they view
freed Freedom as being just total
openness to everything which as we've
said many times on this show that's not
what Freedom actually is that's not what
our Founders thought freedom was that's
not what the great Statesman of our
civilization have thought that freedom
is but I guess my question to them is
you want Total openness you hold as most
sacred just the the total openness to
anything and everything without coming
to any conclusions
whatsoever
why why why is that
good what's so good about presenting a
10-year-old with porn in the classroom
well what do you what do you want to do
ban
books in some cases yes but at least for
certain people and you know in certain
ages but put that aside for a
second why is it good you sound like a
book burner hold on quit it with the
invective quit it with the insults just
can you give me an explanation of why it
is what good is achieved by giving
pornography to a
10-year-old
well then they're really they're really
open right to what end for what our
founding fathers talked about the
blessings of liberty and they had a way
better conception of Liberty than we do
today but when you talk about the
blessings of liberty you recognize that
Liberty is an instrument to an end to a
good it's not a good in and of itself
it's it's a it's a it's a means to an
end so what is the good to be achieved
there they fall silent they would look
at you like you have three heads right
now go to genucell.com
nyt I have got a Christmas gift idea
that is sure to make you the hero of the
Season we all know the holidays can be a
bit hectic the shopping the cooking the
never- ending list of things to do but
fear not because I've discovered a gift
that is not just thoughtful it's
downright transformative the gift of
genus cell skincare from now until
Christmas genu cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at jus.com nsyt letter y
letter T treat yourself and your loved
ones to the absolute best skincare in
the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles Fine Lines skin redness and yes
even a sagging jawline will disappear
right before your eyes with jus cell's
most popular collection Jus cell
promises immediate effects you will see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
or your money back jell made Christmas
come early this year they sent down a
ton of products for the entire office
everyone is raving about their under eye
bag cream and everything else they work
wonders you deserve to look and feel
your best this Christmas season head on
over right now to jus.com
/yt get this incredible holiday discount
you know I love this company I love the
founder of the company a Coptic
Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream it is the highest quality
ingredients out there every order today
upgraded to free express shipping Jus
cell.com
nsyt today schools Across America are
encouraging miners
children to go onto Secret online LGBT
chat rooms to discuss quote gender
affirming
surgeries occult practices believe it or
not and other things with adults who
identify as
LGBT seems to me if any
adults access these platforms they
should get a knock on the door from
Chris Hansen followed by the police but
it's not just that it's not just that
creepy adults are talking about these
things with kids
unsupervised by the kids parents to
without the knowledge of the kids
parents at
all it's that the schools are
encouraging it
Massachusetts has administrators who are
pushing youth to identify as
lgbtqia a plus I guess that's the new
one that's the one they're sticking with
to qchat which is a secret platform that
connects uh chat-based discussion groups
for lgbtq plus they forgot the IIA in
that one but it's got it it they got to
add the IIA I guess the platform is
outdated uh and questioning teens ages
13 to 19 can you
imagine can you imagine you you're a
parent and you find out that some
pervert School administrator told your
13-year-old kid to go onto a secret chat
room to talk with adults about weird sex
stuff can you imagine how difficult it
would be to restrain your worst impulses
and to remember that Vengeance Belongs
to the Lord and to allow the Civil
authority to take its course which it
won't do because the Civil Authority
promotes this can you
fathom that
reaction very difficult very difficult
to imagine restraint in that situation
the these chat rooms invite participants
to join conversations on everything from
queer youth activism to sex and
relationships to tarot cards isn't it
kind of weird isn't it kind of weird how
all this stuff just always seems to come
back to weird satanic imagery isn't that
and like occult practices and Demon
stuff it it's just funny huh funny how
that works all of this of course without
parental permission this website which
is a project of a bunch of LGBT element
groups and plant Parenthood so you you
have the child sacrifice people in there
too they they have even equipped the
website with a Quick Escape so if your
parents walk by and see that your
pervert School administrators have
encouraged you to go talk about sex and
Tarot cards with weird adults whose
identity you don't know you can just
very quickly X out of it and you just
quick escape button you're out so the
parents won't find out you don't want
them to find out because then they might
tell you not to do that and the school
really really the school wants to do the
same thing the pornhub's trying to do to
you okay
Wisconsin it's not just Massachusetts
Wisconsin uh had students guided to
Trevor space which is a similar kind of
thing allows minors who identifies as
LGBT they lost the Q and the IIA and the
plus to anonymously chat with adults on
the platform this is a project of the
Trevor Project which is a radical
LGBT uh
organization uh this has been exposed
for a as a hotspot for graphic
conversations about sexual fetishes
adults giving minors advice on how to
discreetly obtain various uh sexual
paraphernalia and hide it from their
parents very very disturbing adults
detailing I'm not even I'm not even
going to get into it adults detailing
very very disgusting depraved things for
the minors on the chat form on the
platform this is viar Germany kind of
stuff this is late Rome kind of stuff
the worst kind of depravity that you've
ever read about in a history book right
now at perhaps a a a much higher level
going
on obviously I agree with that you very
likely agree with that you you normal
people listening to the show now I know
look I know that there are some left
wiers and even some radical left-wingers
who listen to the show so maybe there
are a small number of you out there
who disagree with me and you say no no
Michael you don't you're totally
misrepresenting this and I'll tell you
from their perspective this is what
they're saying from their perspec
perspective they're saying there are
these kids who are whatever are gay are
they have these
uh sexual desires that are unusual and
they feel alone and they feel isolated
and an oppressive Society with a with a
false and cruel
morality uh forces them to stay in the
closet and deny their true selves and
these heroic adults are out there giving
their time giving their money in many
cases trying to save these poor
oppressed LGBT Elementary P children
from their cruel evil parents and this
evil country founded on evil Christian
morality and they're they're going to
liberate them and bring them into the TR
and fullness of their identity that's
what they say that's what they believe
that's the justification for this and so
from their perspective I think many of
them have good
intentions which by the way pave the
road to hell those good intentions but I
bet they have good intentions some of
them some of them are perverts but some
of
them are are unknowingly perverts and
they they and they probably do have good
intentions they really really believe
all of this so who's right what is it is
this a bunch of weirdos grooming kids
into something that will harm them or is
this a bunch of wonderful helpful people
enlightened Brilliant Minds who are
saving children from oppression and
liberating
them
you know my view and I think I know your
view but it's an open question and and
it's a question that the state will
weigh in on that the state must weigh in
on because the school is going to do one
thing or the other the school is either
going to encourage these chat sites or
the school is not going to encourage
these chat sites the school is going to
teach something it's either going to
teach that a boy can be a girl and
therefore if you're you're a boy but you
think you're a girl then you need to be
liberated and and go on hormones and
chop yourself up and and be called by
the opposite pronouns or it's not going
to teach that the school's going to say
no actually boys can't be girls so
you're just confused and we're going to
we're going to try to give you a more
correct understanding of things but it's
going to teach something this that the
state has to weigh in which means that
the
state has to have some kind of religious
View and even if you don't like the word
Rel you're allergic to it the state has
to take some kind of view of human
nature and who we are how we know who we
are what we're here for those are all
religious questions we can pretend that
they're not if that if you'd prefer that
but either way the state has to have an
answer to it and has to enforce those
standards who's going to do that
traditionally that would be us we the
people that's that's the that's the true
American tradition you will hear the
radical squishes and the radical
individualists and the even the radical
Libertarians in some cases
saying that we have no right to impose
our views on others that's unamerican
now it man this is unamerican you
seriously think Thomas Jefferson would
have supported this no you really think
George Washington would have supported
this kind of Filth and degeneracy of
course not so that means that the view
that you are claiming is the Deep
American true sense of freedom is just
wrong it's just ahistorical you've been
fed a lie you you've bought a bill of
goods okay
and that means we need to correct our
perception first before we can then have
the brains and the spine and maybe some
other body parts to correct that
perception for the country and return to
something resembling a reasonable
American tradition man what a great clip
that was huh now hey vot subscribe ring
that Bell we'll see you next time